good morning could we be facing more
restrictions this festive season the
prime minister has resisted for now but
could he change his mind before new
year's eve after saying they reserved
the right to bring in further measures
what impact will that have on our plans
for celebrations and holidays the head
of the world health organization calling
for people to cancel events in order to
save lives we were keen to see
clarification from the government this
morning but
there's no minister available to clear
up the confusion for you
so we'll analyze the data and the latest
lines with the world health organization
instead first here's laura bondock
arcovid kerbs coming wales isn't waiting
all sporting events behind closed doors
from boxing day
no changes yet in england but the
uncertainty is crippling christmas
business
we are down 20 to 25
on a normal week
when we should be 25 up on a normal week
in the christmas months
landlord scott illman is resigned to
more restrictions but it's a sobering
thought
if it's a short and short one we should
be okay
but it's it's the hardest month of the
year and we haven't made the money in
december to pay our wages in january the
empty tables say it all
we've got plans to go and visit family
we've got friends coming to stay
and it's really difficult to plan any of
that when we don't know what's going to
happen i've told my parents we're not
going to come back if you know
things escalate my mum's ill so we don't
want to put that like that's a risk i
think you know missing a few new years
it is worth it to kind of keep you know
covered in check and things like that
but i i'm also unsure that people even
if regulations were set people would
follow it especially given the
government isn't setting a good example
at all
covid cases are soaring but for now
ministers won't go further with measures
we agreed that we should keep the the
data from now on under constant a review
keep uh following it
hour by hour and
unfortunately i must say to people we we
will have to
reserve the the
possibility of taking further action to
to protect the public
what that action means isn't clear but
already the mayor of london's cancelled
the trafalgar square new year
celebrations and the queens called off
her christmas at sandringham
one in three people who have covert 19
have no symptoms and could be breathing
it out without knowing meanwhile the
push for care caution and vaccines
continues
christmas is coming but so too the
feeling festivities will be short-lived
laura
sky news
well in a difficult week for the prime
minister this was the scene at london's
alexandra palace last night
[Music]
what are they saying well they're saying
stand up if you hate boris will dance
championships fans are not at all happy
others scenes with signs as you can see
showing images of cheese and wine in
this sign which reads all round to boris
is after
meanwhile the head of the world health
organization has called on people to
cancel their holiday plans in order to
save lives
all of us are
sick of this pandemic
all of us want to spend time with
friends and family
all of us want to get back to normal
the fastest way to do this is for all of
us
leaders and individuals
to make the difficult decisions that
must be made to protect ourselves and
others
in some cases
that will mean counseling or delaying
events
just as we have had to cancel the
reception we plan to have with you today
but an event cancelled is better
than a life cancelled
it's better to cancel now and celebrate
later
than to celebrate now and grieve later
margaret harris from the world health
organization with us now hello to you
doctor good morning does the world
health organization really want us to
cancel christmas
good morning kay no that's not what the
director general was saying he was
saying large events so he was actually
referring to a reception a get-together
we'd promised to have with journalists
we'd canceled the one the year before uh
and we cancelled it this year because it
was it's not something that we can do
safely right now and that's the point he
was making if you have gatherings that
are not going to be safe
uh change them delay them do them later
don't do them now what constitutes them
not being safe
well if you've got a large number of
people or a considerable number of
people especially people coming from
different places uh you don't know what
their exposure has been
people coming together in that sort of
circumstance is what we call social
mixing that's the moment at which you're
most likely to spread uh kovid and
particularly omicron
okay i mean okay so let's let's see what
that would mean for christmas lunch then
should we i mean i often have
20 people run my christmas um table
emergency chairs out the shed and the
like is that a bad idea this year
so again it's who you're bringing uh
what is their status have they all been
vaccinated um
do you know or are you taking other
measures are you opening your windows
ventilating your room
um can you space things have they worn
masks so there are lots of things that
you need to do and take into account
when you put your party together
what about lots of little ones running
around because of course they won't have
been vaccinated
indeed and again one of the things you
need to look at is um
not so much
whether they've been vaccinated but
who's coming that is in the
vulnerable group like an older person or
a person who's got underlying conditions
and have they been vaccinated because
the vaccines are really protecting this
group from getting into hospital and
from sadly dying so that's what dr
tedros was saying is please don't put
people who are most likely to suffer
from um the severe form at risk
but of course you can still
contract omicron even if you've had your
booster
indeed it is it omicron is very good at
spreading so the the problem is
people are getting confused between the
severe version
and the actual just the the virus
getting into your body now the vaccines
are really pre designed to keep you out
of hospital protect from the severe
version protect the hospitals from
filling up and of course protect us from
all dying
but they're not so good at
stopping it from getting into your nose
and staying there for a little while
long enough for you to breathe on
somebody else and pass it to them
so lots of people can contract omicron
is what you're saying but not find
themselves in hospital
we're hoping that that's the case
especially in
well-vaccinated populations so that's
why we're saying getting vaccinated is
key but taking all the other measures as
well is crucial because that helps bring
the transmission down and that reduces
the risk so it's like it's the swiss
cheese effect you do lots and lots of
different things to really bring down
the risks really bring down the exposure
then we're in a much better position
so the world health organization is
saying if you're double vaccinated if
you've got your booster if you take
appropriate precautions there's no
reason to lock down
so we're saying we prefer not to see
lockdowns a big lockdown because they
have huge economic implications they
have very severe social implications and
mental health implications however they
do work so governments do get your point
when the hospitals are overwhelmed where
they run out of options
uh minimize um travel um
where is one suggestion step two that
the prime minister might introduce um as
early as the 27th of december finding
people if they travel what's the world
health organization's view on travel
so again we ask people to take all
precautions and traveling is a moment
where you're very likely to be mixing
with a lot of different people from
different places whose vaccination
status you don't know and you're likely
to be in a position where you're in a
crowded poorly ventilated spot so your
risk dose does go up a lot so again this
is something you need to think about
why am i traveling do i really need to
travel at this moment can i travel later
and travel safely and have a really
happy and healthy christmas
from what you're saying it does sound as
though the world health organization
feels that the british government is
probably
in or about the right place at the
moment and there's no need for any
further restrictions
so we don't give marks to any individual
country we understand that leadership
and health authorities
tailor their measures and their
decisions according to the epidemiology
in their populations but also the
cultural and behavioral dynamics that
work in their populations but the
overall message is limit crowding and
take the measures if you take the
measures if you're out and about that
will protect you like wearing the mask
and wearing the mask properly please
wear it over your nose everybody
at the nose out of the mask that's not
working that's not helping anyone
and um make sure that you do the hand
washing the distancing and really really
seriously get vaccinated not just get
vaccinated but if you know someone who's
still struggling with the idea of being
vaccinated help them to get vaccinated
um when will we know whether omicron
is
as big a worry as delta was
so we're already getting um a very
strong message that it's much more
transmissible and that in itself
is a very serious threat because
um even if most people do not have the
severe disease especially because we've
got a well vaccinated population
if you've got huge numbers of people
infected you will have a small
percentage who get the severe form of
and that translates into big numbers
because
you know one percent of millions is a
lot of people uh so
it's already very clear that it's a very
serious threat
and what's the world health organization
on the mental health impact on younger
people who say
you asked us to have three inoculations
to keep the rest of the country um well
we've done that we cannot be locked down
anymore
well certainly that's why we're saying
we do we prefer that governments do not
get to the point that your epidemiology
does not get to the point where
governments need to make that feel they
need to make that decision because
indeed the mental health impacts are
very serious and we have seen
a big rise in
in mental health suffering during this
period so peop if you do go into
lockdown
look at how you can support people what
you can do to alleviate the suffering
that it does cause
uh always informative thank you so much
for joining us doctor we much appreciate
it thank you it's a pleasure to be with
you thank you merry christmas
now let's look at some of the tougher
measures we could be looking at given
what we just heard there from the world
health organization in step two there
you go it's very different
to tier two okay so you need to bear
that in mind there was easing of some
lockdown restrictions such as the
opening of non-essential retail and
personal care if you take yourself back
to the 12th of april last year this is
what was happening but there was no
socializing indoors except with the same
household or inside a support bubble
meetings outdoors were allowed including
in gardens for groups of six people or
between two households and people who
lived in care homes in england were
allowed two named regular indoor
visitors
our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen is with us now it is important to
make the difference isn't it between
tier 2 and step 2 tomorrow first of all
that's right if you remember the road
map at the beginning of the beginning of
this year we were in a very strict
lockdown of course in january and boris
johnson announced there will be a series
of steps of reopening step one being
children back to school step two as you
say in mid april being you could sit in
a hospitality venue but only outside and
there was still no indoor mixing now why
do we need to think back to those steps
because the scientists advising the
government on the sage committee
published their minutes on saturday
pretty gloomy reading saying if the
government wants to stem hospital
admissions they think are coming down
the track we may need to return to step
two or even step one in the coming days
if they want to make a dent in those now
i understand that the possibility of
step two no indoor mixing with anyone
apart from your household only sitting
outside with something that was
discussed yesterday at boris johnson's
cabinet meeting now it wasn't that the
prime minister said let's do this and
the rest of the cabinet said no they had
a frank discussion about it but it seems
that a lot of cabinet ministers and
particularly the chancellor didn't want
to take any more measures at the moment
until they've got more data despite the
scientists telling them you need to act
sooner rather than later so it was
discussed yesterday nothing so far but
as you heard the prime minister wants to
keep it all in reserve so it all feels a
little bit when not if but that's the
sort of that's the sort of measures that
are now being discussed going forward
okay now that was in april of last year
when those measures came in this is what
happened with matt hancock in a news
conference in downing street
the following month
people can now spend time outdoors and
exercise as often as you like
and you can meet one other person from
outside your household
in an outdoor public place but please
keep two meters apart
this weekend with the good weather and
the new rules i hope people can enjoy
being outside
but please stick with the rules keep an
eye on your family and don't take risks
so step two was still in place uh and uh
just about a few minutes after that news
conference this is what was happening
in the garden of dining street and the
guy there with his back tea with the
suit
that according to some
is matt hancock doing exactly what he
told people
not to do
or is he i don't know let's find out
what tomorrow thinks your take on that
tomorrow
well okay yes matt hancock has admitted
being in downing street on that day the
day we believe of a press conference he
said that he debriefed with the prime
minister and then he left to go back to
the department of health we have not
independently verified that that is matt
hancock but that is what's being
reported and of course this is the same
month that he was pictured with his aide
at the department of health which led to
his resignation so already accusations
that matt hancock was not not
accusations he's admitted not following
the rules at that stage of the pandemic
and now an accusation that he was
actually at this downing street
gathering when everybody else as we've
heard some really tragic situations of
people's elderly relatives dying alone
people going to huge lengths to try and
follow
those rules so this again another
example
many think of the government telling
people to do one thing and they
themselves doing another now unlike the
downing street christmas gathering which
is still being investigated
on this
gathering the government have been
pretty defensive and boris johnson who
was answering questions yesterday
claimed it was work gathering talking
about work although it was pointed out
to him that there don't seem to be many
laptops in sight and there are bottles
of wine and cheese in sight but the
government very much standing firm on
that being a work meeting
in suits as dominic raab told you
yesterday so that is what they are
saying we'll make our own minds up i'm
sure
okay uh when do you just before i let
you go when do you think with no
minister today i'm not sure why but
there we go hopefully they'll be back
with us tomorrow um when might we hear
more about when we the restrictions
could be just to underline that point so
boris johnson didn't rule out
restrictions before christmas yes some
people think it's unlikely because they
haven't brought them in yet but he
didn't rule it out number 10 have
stressed that to me again today that he
didn't rule it out i expect kaye that
we'll get more data this week and there
will be another cabinet meeting this
week
so far i think mps are gearing up for a
recall of parliament to vote on possible
restrictions next week but there's no
guarantee that it won't be earlier
okay thanks tamara um let's bring in
katie she's in trafalgar square for us
there were supposed to be about six and
a half thousand people gathering there
weren't there on new year's eve what's
happened
there were okay and of course this is
the second year running now that new
year's eve celebrations have been
cancelled here in london it was moved
here to trafalgar square for a slightly
smaller event as you say about six and a
half people i think there's normally 10
000 or more on the southbank because of
continued fares over the pandemic but
the mayor now sadiq khan saying that uh
because of the surge in omicron cases
here in london at the event simply
cannot go ahead in any form at all and
essentially what he's doing really is
firing a warning shot to the government
saying things are really bad here and we
need more help he has been calling
repeatedly for additional support for
businesses here in london particularly
the hospitality center but at the
hospitality sector bars pubs restaurants
which of course rely so heavily on being
really busy at this time of year around
christmas and new year and the
uncertainty over new restrictions coming
in has absolutely decimated their
bookings and mr khan saying without
additional support right now jobs will
be lost and of course this all comes
after the mayor declared a major
incident here in london over the weekend
essentially because he was uh frightened
of how much
covert related absences were going to
impact the emergency services we have
however heard from the met police and
london's fire brigade who say at the
moment they are managing to run a normal
service despite higher than average
levels of absences london ambulance
service however though saying that they
are extremely busy but they will do
everything they can to get people who
need them over this winter period okay
thank you
also making the news for us this morning
donald trump has been booed after
admitting getting a covid booster the
former u.s president revealed he got the
job during an event in texas with former
tv presenter bill o'reilly
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't no no no
that's a very tiny group over there
up to a thousand passengers on the queen
mary the second could be facing
christmas in isolation after a covered
outbreak on their cruise from
southampton to new york
the daily express reports that around 60
passengers have tested positive and are
being kept in their cabins in an
isolation corridor
the during the sex trafficking trial of
gillane maxwell have begun their
deliberations during closing arguments
in new york prosecutors described her as
a grown woman who preyed on vulnerable
kids but lawyers for the former
girlfriend of the convicted pedophile
jeffrey epstein denies she groomed young
girls for him to abuse
the death toll from the super typhoon
which uh hit the philippines last week
has now reached 375
rescuers have warned the number of dead
may increase further as many towns and
villages remain cut off it's estimated
more than 400 000 people have been left
homeless
the government science work with uh will
begin this week to electrify the midland
mainline rail network the scheme came
under fire last month after the eastern
leg of hs2 between the east midlands and
leeds was scrapped
ministers insist their integrated rail
plan will transform rail services in the
midlands and the north
i look away now if you don't like creepy
crawlies giant millipedes as long as a
car and weighing
50 kilos were once hunted across
northern england according to experts at
the university of cambridge they say the
creature known as the arthropleura
was most likely to have been seen a
hundred million years before the age of
the dinosaur
and police in ohio have presented a 27
year old with a bravery award after he
tackled a man suspected of stealing a
pensionless handbag there you go that's
what he did oh goodness that went
through quickly didn't it we'll recap
that for you surveillance footage shows
deshawn presley chasing derek vaughan
outside a grocery store in lemon
township earlier this month there was a
violent struggle between the two men
sorry about that
we'll show you that um in a bit more
detail coming up later on he basically
stole the 87 year old's puss um there we
go should we slow it down a bit for you
there you go he was having none of it
grabbed hold of him let's take a look at
the front pages for you should we the
guardian says that even though covert is
surging the cabinet split means there'll
be no extra curbs or restrictions at
least for now the financial times
reports that the prime minister faces
cabinet deadlock over whether to bring
in any tighter coveted restrictions in
time for christmas
the eye reports that ministers demanded
more data on the impact of the omicron
variant during yesterday's emergency
cabinet meeting they understand
statistics about its severity will be
available before christmas and should
then be able to be used to help the pm
decide on restrictions
daily mail says the same their headline
rejoice christmas is looking safe
and the mirror leads with news that the
queen will spend christmas at windsor
instead of sandringham breaking her
festive tradition for the second year
running
so she's decided to stay at windsor
rather than heading to sandringham which
is what she would normally do but will
she have family with her angela levin is
joining us uh royal biographer of course
hello angela thanks for joining us good
morning she's going to be devastated
isn't she
i think she is of course she's been
looking for this um
for a long time now because she's been
so isolated and been on her own and
she's used to being with lots of people
and she loves her family and i think she
loves the grandchildren and the great
grandchildren
even more than her own now because
they're up and going their own way and
she just adores the little ones and it
also proves to her that the
monarchy is just going on and on which
is what she really uh cares about
and it is a shame because as you said
it's it's
she didn't go
to sandringham last year and actually
since 1988
um sandringham has been the place where
all the royals gathered for christmas
and her majesty likes routine she likes
loyalty she likes things to be as they
always has
she
changes things you know imperceptibly
but basically she likes the routine that
she's
had for well 70 years
um
so i don't think she will be on her own
i'm quite sure that the royals who are
close to her will make arrangements uh
as they did soon after prince philip's
death whereby they had um times for each
of them to go and see her and keep her
company and i think that that will work
very well and of course it doesn't mean
she won't be able to go up to
sandringham at all she does like to be
there in january she usually comes back
on the 6th of february so she can um
enjoy
the walking and the the views um later
but 50 people were due there and i think
that is really too much and most
important of all she wants to keep
herself going for the platinum jubilee
next spring
and
she's going to have a wonderful time
because it's a day with the horses which
she loves there's going to be prayers in
in chapel there's going to be all sorts
of things people all around the country
are going to have um get together and
eat and be joyous and the concert
everything you can think of that she
would like and it'd be wonderful because
she is the first monarch to have ever
been on the throne for over 70 years and
i think that that although she's not a
grandiose person in any way other than
being queen um she she would love to
have that in the history books
i'm sure uh who do you think will be
whether on christmas day
well i think probably the the locals
will be um that um
prince andrew will be there and the um
uh
contest of essex with louise i mean
louise uh now sort of just 18. she gets
on extremely well with the queen and
she's very gentle and kind and i think
they will they might take it in turns um
prince charles and camilla will
certainly be there maybe not on
christmas day boxing day but i think the
um cambridges william and catherine will
go after that because they've got small
children and i think it's quite
difficult and they can also go to see
katherine's family which
william will love because he's so close
to them i mean that's just my guess but
i think the people who are close to her
will be there
uh for her and also she's got some of
her own stuff because who she's very
very close to including angela kelly
who's been her dressmaker and advisor
and companion for many years now and she
um will always give up anything to be
with her majesty because she admires her
and they get on so well so i think she's
such an interesting fit that isn't it
she's actually a scouser isn't she um
but i remember telling a fantastic story
um over the dinner table once about how
she'd had to sell her washing machine to
buy an appropriate frock to have her
interview with the queen and she told
the queen the story and she got the job
yes
well the queen's got a great sense of
humor and i think she would think that
was you know a really sort of wacky
answer
as to why she wanted the job and and i
don't think people would sell their
washing machine for a dress unless they
were really keen and and her judgment's
been right she's been wonderful to her
and the queen has looked so smart
and colorful and and um
quietly modern in what she's worn lately
yeah with angela's uh advice or not with
the scarf over her head but you know
when she's on duty she yeah
i think she's been beavering a beavering
away actually of late i think she um
received was it the sultan of oman
um quite recently um i'd you talked
about who may or may not be available to
spend christmas um with her i i'm
surprised that perhaps um charles
wouldn't go
yeah i said that i'm sure yeah they
would go because i think they might be
at high growth um they won't go up to
scotland yet which they always do but
they might be in high ground and that
would be very easy and and charles is
very devoted to his mother always has
been wants to please her and and camilla
now gets on with her incredibly well
she's accepted totally um they have lots
in common like horses and dogs which
they can talk about for ages and also my
goodness isn't she working hard she's
taking on more and more patronages
than almost anybody else i mean almost
every day there's another one and she
does it thoroughly she doesn't just want
her name on a on a note paper
um
sorry to interrupt do you think that she
um is doing what she's done cancel the
christmas in order to offer support to
her government or because she is anxious
about omicron herself
i think it's very much to show
the country as an example of making a
decision that is very difficult but
perhaps is the right one
and she
wants to
seem and i think she's done that for the
last few years to be the same as us you
know when the pandemic arrived in
2020 uh we desperately wanted her to
speak to us and 23 million people
listened to her to say we will get by we
will get on and and it was that she was
just one of us and looking after us as a
sort of grandmother should really um and
i think that she wants to
set a good example
okay it's always great to talk to you
angela you've always got such great
insight thank you so much for joining us
thank you bye thank you bye-bye
the volcano on la palma has appeared to
have stopped
police officers on la palma have taken
to feeding cats in the area who have
been left homeless by the destruction
from the volcano there you go the
volcano went quite last week and
scientists say this may signal the end
but will not declare the eruption
officially over unless the lack of
seismic activity continues
through until christmas eve and then
there's an awful lot of clearing up to
do isn't there
meanwhile demand has erupted for wine
that shares its name with the la palma
volcano cells of cumbre viejo red wine
have soared since the eruption began
three months ago providing an unexpected
windfall for its vineyard there you go
forecasters say there is a chance of
snow in britain on christmas day will we
see some snow down south again the
official forecast says the parts of the
country most likely to see snowfall are
scotland
the far north of england and northern
ireland but they are warning the outlook
remains
uncertain
here is in more detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
more unsettled midweek bringing an
increasing risk of ice and snow as we
head towards the christmas period
relatively quiet picture just now with
most places starting the day on a cloudy
note
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so no minister for you today so i'm not
sure what the latest figures are as far
as omicron and the number of people in
hospital is concerned we'll try and get
that for you but we can tell you that
the list of events canceled across the
uk due to the omicron variant continues
to grow
last night london's new zealand
celebrations in trafalgar square just
hearing about that weren't we they've
been called off and around europe
restrictions are being tightened the
netherlands has the toughest rules the
whole country is now back in full
lockdown until at least the 14th of
january my goodness germany says anyone
arriving from the uk must go into
quarantine for two weeks regardless of
their vaccination status
in denmark all cinemas theaters and
museums have been closed france has
enforced its health pass meaning people
have to be fully vaccinated to get into
restaurants museums
and sporting events
official new year's eve fireworks and
public parties are also cancelled
and in ireland all restaurants and bars
apart from takeaways and delivery
services now close at 8 pm from dublin
our island correspondent stephen murphy
reports
7 p.m
8 p.m
this is how irish night out are now over
at eight until at least the end of
january
for me it doesn't bother me i'm i'm
happy enough to have a few points and
leave at eight o'clock but for younger
people it's much more difficult i think
do you think people just drink in houses
now oh absolutely i don't see people are
people are going to be in a situation
where they have no
there's no kind of
barriers or restrictions or anything
holding people back people are going to
be absolutely hammered in gaffes and
just spreading it even further is that
what you're doing now i i will be doing
it though that's the worst part sorry
about this
republicans say they've been left
bewildered by the new restrictions
no
literally a couple of minutes after
eight o'clock christmas week and it's
completely deserving
yeah it's just surreal uh i've done some
strange things in my time but that's
right up there i mean it just feels kind
of ridiculous it feels pointless it
feels wrong
and uh very it's actually very upsetting
just knowing your business is just
getting destroyed slowly but surely
the new rules have been put in place
because of the rise of omicron which in
the space of just two weeks has
overtaken delta to become ireland's
dominant strain the government has
warned of record case numbers in the
coming days as it urges people to get
their booster shots but once again the
hospitality industry feels it's being
made an easy scapegoat
we feel pretty devastated to be honest
in the dublin suburbs republican deirdre
devitt has spent tens of thousands of
euro on outdoor seating a coffee van and
filtration systems but now she's going
to be hit hard in the pocket again
the bar here opens at 12. it's opening
from 12 to 8 pm viable for you we have
absolutely no idea stephen if it's
viable because we don't know what's
coming we're one of the most social
countries in the world
every celebration is had in pubs and
restaurants and hotels and you know
there's pubs friends of mine pubs and
restaurants that are empty and it's
christmas week
we cannot continue like this shutting up
by 8pm may kill the christmas spirit for
punters but it's the businesses that are
really suffering despite renewed
financial supports from government irish
pubs and restaurants simply can't afford
to keep opening and closing
nearly two years on they say there's
still no plan for truly living with
covid
stephen murphy sky news in
dublin latest covered figures for the uk
for you a further 91 000 new cover cases
44 new deaths sadly have been recorded
brings the total number of deaths
to 147
2261. as for vaccines 33 000 first doses
have been delivered an additional almost
uh 40 000
second doses
total number of second doses now more
than 47 and a half million
uh look at these uh booster doses um 846
4466 boosters have been delivered in the
last 24 hours which brings the total
amount of boosters delivered
pushing 29 million more than half of the
adult population in terms of omicron
there have been an additional 8 000
cases of the omicron variant reported
across the uk
total number of confirmed omicron cases
in the uk now add up to forty five
thousand
one hundred and forty five
those thousands of covid patients are
being treated by hospital staff across
the country their treatment will have to
continue
throughout the holidays joining us now
covered icu anesthetist dr um
ed patrick hello to ed thanks for
joining us what's it been like in icu
over the last few days hi okay love to
join you again um
it's been pretty much the same it has
been for the last few months so we still
have uh covered patients coming into
hospital into icu i think one of the
things that's happening is that people
are just wondering what's going to
happen over the next couple of weeks and
how it's going to affect
admissions but also i think staffing as
well because obviously if other people
are getting it and needing to go off
sick that might be a big issue for the
nhs
how worried are you
about the omicron cases have you had any
so it's difficult to say what we've had
because that sort of information doesn't
really filter down to us so we get
whether someone's actually covered
positive but we never get to the point
of actually hearing whether it's omicron
or not so those statistics aren't
feeding down um but that'll be quite
useful when you're treating them
it might
it might be useful just to know
what it's like on the ground
but the treatment is still going to be
the same so i think that's the what
people would say about it but it would i
think it would be helpful just to know
you know region by region where that is
what do you say to people who are still
reluctant to get their jobs i mean i'm
always surprised when we read out the
number of people that are going for
their first vaccination another 30 000
people yesterday decided oh all right
then i'll have one
so what i'd say to people who are still
hesitant is that when you if you end up
with covert and end up coming into
hospital is that you need a cocktail of
drugs in order to keep you alive when
you're in intensive care all of which
have side effects so that can be avoided
if the vaccine can stop you from getting
severely ill and the other thing to say
is you know people talk about um side
effects with vaccine things or that
they're worried about things like clots
well uh covert can give you uh clots and
people who come into hospital who are
suffering from covid will go on to
medication to help stop their blood
clotting to that extent so um all this
can be avoided by having a vaccine so if
you are on the fence about it um or
still wondering i'd definitely recommend
getting one
and do you find
there is unvaccinated
remorse when people come in and they say
i wish i'd had
the vaccination when i could
i think people definitely think about
whether they could turn back time
because obviously you can't give the
vaccine once you're in hospital it's a
preventative thing so once it's
once that horse is bolted there's no
going back um to give the vaccine i
think
there's definitely feelings of remorse
and obviously frustration from all sides
around that this could possibly have
been prevented
yeah do you see many people
in icu that have been vaccinated
it's uh it's more
it's mostly unvaccinated people i see in
icu people who are vaccinated
um are there with other problems that
possibly affect their immune system
meaning that they don't respond as well
to the vaccine but the vast vast
majority at the moment
are unvaccinated obviously we don't know
what's going to happen in the next
few weeks
when there's a possible worry about
surgical infections and whether that
changes or not so we'll have to see just
then final thought what are you
expecting to see that surge
there's a possible talk of
surging in patients coming in january at
some point and i think there's we're
talking about planning of how we can
sort of deal with uh staff and if
there's any staff shortages um so i
think that's the time when we're
expecting because obviously there's a
lag between when you get infected when
you become unwell and then when you
become so unwell that you actually need
hospital treatment and so we're thinking
uh the thinking is that that's going to
be in january okay good to talk to you
doctor keep well thank you thank you
is there any hope of foreign travel this
winter we all side are we joining us
claire evan travel editor at the
telegraph hi chloe we spoke to you or
you certainly uh used one of your tweets
last week when we found out what france
were doing now we're hearing that
potentially step two could be brought in
don't know if it will it could be which
means that if you try and travel
overseas you get fined five thousand
pounds
yeah and that's the cost i think many
people haven't factored into their
holiday
um
i mean
firstly of course there is confusion
between um whether it's tier two or step
two of course nothing's been confirmed
um let me say step two is a a much more
serious implication for not just for
international travel but for any of us
hoping to um you know spend time with
with family um and friends either
overseas or even domestically um so it's
you know it if that is brought in it
will be another blow and and
interestingly it also contradicts what
the health secretary said about travel
restrictions when
a couple of weeks ago they they scrapped
the red list
because their thinking was well
omicron's so um widely spread that in
actual fact travel restrictions are
pretty pointless um
so of course what that thinking does is
open up travel to those people who
have the ability to to be a bit flexible
um who who can afford any extra testing
and so on around that
and and you know really want to be able
to travel and to travel safely
um of course it has so great
implications for those people and for
people as i say hoping to meet up but
you know the industry that supports our
holiday that helps us actually get there
you know the hotels the ground staff the
airlines so um you know a step two would
be a very bleak um introduction for for
the trampoline street and any of us
hoping to use it
what about just the threat of step two
what does that what advice would you
give people this morning
i mean yesterday i was talking to
hoteliers you know i went into a couple
of hotel lobbies and
you know the impact already of the last
10 days is immense i mean we're talking
hundreds of thousands of pounds impact
on individual hotels and restaurants i'm
talking to one gm yesterday who said
that they have they have a really high
repeat uh level of
guests
and um in the last week they'd had
guests phoning up in the morning to
cancel and then phoning up again in the
in the afternoon to rebook for that same
evening because
indecision is
is so
um just completely
it erodes confidence and that's the
biggest problem facing the travel
industry apart from you know just
actual closure
but but this kind of stealth closure
um you know whereby people don't feel
comfortable going for dinner or don't
feel comfortable honoring a note a hotel
booking
is is decimating um those industries and
indeed then as i say the experience that
we all
have then when we we finally can travel
because there isn't staff you know there
isn't infrastructure
um and
you know and it risks standard slipping
so all in all it's um it's bad news
what advice would you give
to families who are potentially they
have christmas at home and then they're
either going for a sunshine holiday or
they're going um
skiing on boxing day should they still
go
well
my advice would be the same as it's been
throughout the pandemic is be flexible
be open-minded and we have lots of
advice on
ski swaps
so for example if you've got a scheme
today booked and
you were hoping to go to france there
are other options um you know there are
sea results in other countries that you
can travel to that have availability um
there are ways that you can travel there
quite cost effectively um but as we've
been saying all the way through the
pandemic
book with a bonded tour appraiser at all
bonded tour operator because then you
know you'll get your money back then
you'll know you'll be supported if you
need to um to isolate or find an
alternative accommodation sorry to
interrupt claire but what happens if
step two comes in the day after you
travel
um i think if we go by tier two well
you're already there so you you get to
finish your holiday and come back yeah
effectively business yeah it's tricky
though isn't it to
know what i should do
yeah i was if you're in that situation i
would just enjoy your holiday while you
can
it's a very good uh tip merry christmas
i hope you have a good one thank you
very much claire oven from the telegraph
thank you
now a new exhibition aims to highlight
the impact of climate change by showing
its effects in some of the most remote
and beautiful places
on earth
this is one of the photos a picture of a
little penguin taken in antarctica and
here we have this mix of landscape in
greenland beautiful
joining us now is amy vitale founder of
the vital impacts and national
geographic photographer and filmmaker
and marcy james paper and ink studio
owners hello to you both thank you so
much for joining us on the program this
morning um so tell us more about your
work ladies
well hello yes we um we
basically decided to i
work with national geographic and
have this rare opportunity to be
connected to so many extraordinary
photographers artists and
basically decided to create a print sale
where we can
sell this art and raise much needed
funding for incredible conservation
happening all over the planet and i'm
really excited because one of the stars
of this is jane goodall herself and
you know we asked her if she
made any photographs and in fact she she
has and so we have these really
beautiful
even a self-portrait which she saw in
front of james
so basically we've got a hundred of the
world's finest
artists and photographers
um names you you may know of like nick
brandt jim naughton
paul nicklin beth moon so many
incredible artists and
um and then people that you may not know
of as well we really searched to find
just uh beautiful new voices that are
out there
and they're shared as we look at these
pictures in more detail um ladies
perhaps you'd like to talk us through
them i don't know if you can see them
great picture of a dolphin there and
where people can see more of them yes so
the website is vital impacts with an
s.org
and the the photographers are are all
incredibly diverse but their one
shared
uh commitment is to the environment and
so all of these images you know it's a
range of work from wildlife
photographers but also artists and they
all really speak about the planet where
we're going and i think you know i think
the idea is to connect
your heart and mind because there's this
really strong connection between images
and empathy
and i believe that you know
that will help us um
you know feel love and compassion for
all the animals and and this planet that
we share with
yeah
so we also have a partner in london the
um the print space so they're helping
fulfill those orders and and you're
carbon neutral here and and yeah so we
just broadened this year to incorporate
the print space so they print out of
london and as well as germany
and they ship to um all of the locations
internationally i cover all of
the shipping for
you for the united states and the main
reason why we wanted to do this was for
um sustainability so that aren't
traveling such a long distance amazing
photos ladies it's absolutely fantastic
to talk to you thank you so much for
sharing them with us this morning merry
christmas merry christmas thanks a lot
bye-bye thank you